と思う
実は今すぐ帰りたいというのも加盟の古い感じとかが結構伝わると思うんですけども私
今どこに言うかといいますと
千葉県のとある閑静な住宅街にある
事故物件に来ておりますもう今部屋にいます事故物件
ちゃんと許可をとって事故物件に切って道が残っている
色々とで自分ルールがあるんですけどできる限りいる動画とっていきたいとおもいます
事故物件に
私今日からメッセージ住んでみようと思います完全に1人でさっきのブームのスタッフ
の人に車でをされてもみんな帰ってしまいました
1人持つ者たちと見てみますでブックローとトイレットペーパー突破たーーーー犬4判
結構
白いんですよ
&したお家ででまぁここが玄関で所の高いってみましょうか
早速探索してみましょう1なり上にわかる玄関があるねうわぁ
港へ
何か大きな店ですねうわめっちゃ埃っぽいなもうちょっと靴下の横
埃っぽすぎるのでも誇り汗に着く前てる以降廊下でここが
大きなお部屋ですねなるほどなるほど
あーでも割と綺麗なお部屋もあるの
あーこわいこわい会
やってみましょうか
なんか結構きれいに使われていた感情がありますこっちはう
メッツきれいメッツ切れ栄光だけカッコイードはだな
なにこれ
ん
おっ
えっ開かないんだけどそんなことある
鉄粉
ああはい鳥肌たちましたさあ何か貼ってあったっぽいなぁ
ブーブーねさっきの廊下に戻ってきますとアーマーああっお風呂場ティコ兄ちゃんこれ
もう
床がすごいの大丈夫
本当に5つのいつから使われてないんだこれが洗面所ですね
[音楽]
僕の子
はこちらの部屋が後入れかじゃあ続いちゃう会に行きますかー
なんか上の方がある子は員さんの4年間振って基礎上からなんかに眉と綺麗な気はする
んだよ
2階です
結構部屋がありそうね
連れします a
根暗すぎんかー
[音楽]
え
通じてついてもメっちゃっ時間差でついたなぁ
こえー
まあでもここが普通の年間誰かが住んでいたんだろうなんて感じちゃうに前住んでた方
が一人暮らしだったみたいですね
を船免状
でこっちかまあ
まず何もないよ部屋
うーんなるほど
なるほど
公園ダメなんですよ
ずここはこんな感じですね本局把握し
一番多くの部屋ですね
入りました終わってもでもでもでもまあ普通の部屋ですねなんでこういうのを全開にし
ておく強い声が進みました閉め場所はこういうの全開にしておくのが一番声と思ってる
しメールも教えてもらって
マジでこの動画に関しては僕しか言えませんからでしょうかはいという感じだっており
ます俺とこで生活しようかなちょっと生活空間決めようか
[音楽]
中間とりあえず1階の和室に入ることにしました
なんか一番きれいだったしちょっと作業とかもあるんでも組んだまだ開かない扉まず
いやわかんないような
同様か方
ずっちゃはないもん
リハ中でも上げ方銅山ないと重なってましたよは金谷勉というちょっとこちらで生活さ
せていただきます
[音楽]
どうせだったらこの事故物件でれたい企画があったんですけどやりましょう壁行こうか
ちょっとほんとさ俺さ
ここでよるスゴ村やばくないですか誰かよでも良かったの一人だけでもじゃあこの一番
壱番屋はそこにあります
サークの一番山形やでー
free to bar マン書庫4つ買ってきたので
ねえ
開けていきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
これでた人を使いうちに
1人名
tb のよっ2
だけ
いい
[音楽]
はいああ
ああああああ
きりたんぽっちゃ
はい
パーティー
煽りたいなっちゃってるんだそうです
最後だ
はい僕ですねえぇなんてやってる間にもう夜ですねそれあの
掃除されてないからホコリがちょっと北
ハウスダストなんで
配当表現よ10時くらいかな
夜になりましたもうまあ kura ですね
ちょっとまた強さの次元がすがって切るなぁ知ればと
好きです
トイレに行きたくなってしまいましたもうさすがにあの9時とかになるとさ
トイレ行くのだけでも相当ハードルが高いわけですよ
いやーちょっと本当に加え
ok
はい日付が変わりました魔女の中でございますさすぐにここでねませんやこんな畳の
ような7万ドル良い環境で俺は育ってきた満たない俺もさっきのあの一番シミが
すごかったよ壱番屋さんの部屋でもちろん
ねます
の前にですね
あのお風呂は許してくださいこちらのお風呂はほんと把握て無理なんですけども一応夜
になったということで深夜の事故物件
なんか色々見ていきたいとおもいます
何も感じで言っちゃう人になりますけど今のところそんな大丈夫そうですね
こわいなへ
[音楽]
[拍手]
壁のに色がもうやっぱり色あせてるからですから出ちゃってるから
ん
キッチンですねあ
特殊な音が吸ったとかは今のところなさそうです
だから俺は滋賀ああ
いやもう来ませんね由加丸掃除してやったぜねいう楽勝なんでしょうけどを from
ところも強すぎで吹いれることすらもう
寿司を袋のだけ目社説死んだよな
中洲ね
まってなんかホントに強い前
トイレは範囲変わらず大丈夫ですトイレットベーパーセッティングしました
仮定法連でねいうこれマジでっ
植木ます
寝れないからねやがやっぱ買ったら電気つけたいとなってかかったなぁ
電気つけておいたからさこの部屋とは結構開かないんですよ
[音楽]
敵作っ
通知音
ついてがまだなぜ頑張れ上動画なってがんばってがんばって
そう頑張って
ダメか一番良いですそれじゃああー
ご趣味ならやですね
ってよああ一番強い奴じゃ
よし
こっから耐久戦だ
4つ
何もないと思うけどなずっとすごいでもつかしかした田中寝るの結果やばいと思うけど
とりあえず
寝ると決めたら寝るおやすみなさい
[音楽]
ねえねえはパツパツはうるさすぎ濡れませんね
怖いよ
あの
となりですか
[音楽]
[拍手]
というわけで無事に1番
過ごすことができました二個分金といって何かあるわけではないと思っているんです
けど
けどやっぱりその他ってものが綺麗にされてないからそういう恐怖とかはあったんです
けど意外と大丈夫でしたねあと僕もあの霊道読者に絶対とりつかれないと言われてるん
でこれが2がかも知れませんし真実は分からないです
けども今回は大丈夫でございました常ルアーも本当に強かった者の田鶏チカチカがマジ
ヤバかったんですけども
とりあえず購入物件も読む方にはあるよという動画でございました
じゃあ回にも気を付けます
[音楽]